Aaron Carter in tears after a DUI arrest
I'm in tears after Rihanna shut down the
valerian premiere plus this internet
trolls push ed Sheeran off Twitter
apparently everybody is feeling a lot of
emotions today folks hey friends and
welcome back to the daily Denny I'm
Denny direct oh and today I am serving
you reread I'm serving you Cara
Delevingne
a little as Sheeran and our new
interview with Bachelorette Rachel
Lindsay but first we've got to get into
this Aaron Carter drama the former teen
idol was busted on suspicion of DUI and
possession of marijuana and drug related
objects on Saturday but Aaron is
fighting back he believes his celebrity
was targeted and et sat down with Aaron
to clear it all up and as you can tell
from this the interview quickly turned
emotional and people see this mugshot
they think you know this is a picture of
a drug addict are you a drug addict you
know
are you on any drugs at all right now
no what do you take I take xanax
propranolol for high blood pressure
medication and I took oxycodones for
miles
are you still on knocking on what
different stops and you see this idea
I'm broken man okay were looking heart
broken four days of no sleep guarding my
gulf outside of a car making sure she
was safe driving all over United States
of America trying to get to my radio
shows doing the best that I can
trying to show up so people will give up
on the end game because they gave up on
me who gave up on you the mouse could
you say I would say my brother I would
say a lot of my fans now that's not all
he had to say about his brother Nick who
shortly after Aaron was arrested tweeted
to my brother I love you no matter what
and if you feel the need to reach out
for help
I am here
and willing to help you get better now
take a look at what Aaron thought of
that I don't mean mix help I don't need
that I don't need help what I need is
people to understand that I'm human and
I make mistakes just like every other
human in this world there's plenty more
where that came from
you can catch more of our exclusive
interview with Aaron tonight on ET but
switching gears now to Rihanna who truly
shut down the black carpet at the
valerian premiere looking like a cotton
candy dream I mean just look at her
RiRi frothy peep John Bautista Valley
ensemble was truly out of this world
from the super long train poofy sleeves
and ribbon laced up so letõs the fantasy
look was on point and the movie's
leading lady super model turned actress
cara delevingne went with the movie's
sci-fi theme donning a silver metallic
dress serving us some spacesuit vibes
and cara agreed here's what she told ET
about her futuristic look gotta start
with this what inspired this look I mean
you look amazing and what's a how about
a little secret a little treat soup did
really my iris can happen beautiful
justice no it's part of valerian a space
from John metal gray you know trying to
go for it my first big movie had the
Chinese at this time we're excited all
right guys I got a chance to see
valerian just a couple weeks ago and it
is something else I literally felt like
I was on a ride the whole time and just
wait until you see Rihanna in this movie
she plays a shape-shifting alien named
bubbles and it's amazing well the
special look at how they pulled off 3:16
in the movie plus my interviews with
Cara and co-star Dane DeHaan Thursday
while we're at Comic Con cannot wait for
that all right from Rihanna's latest
big-screen adventure to Ed Sheeran's
small screen backlash more than 16
million people and Counting have watched
the game of Thrones premiere the most
ever for the series but apparently some
of y'all weren't happy about seeing ad
make an appearance here it is for those
of you who might have missed it for
hands of gold
a woman hands are warm for hands of gold
are all a cold little woman pretty song
I've never had it before the new one
alright that is a little random I'm not
going to lie but to be fair when we talk
to Ed about his cameo even he thought it
was a little too hyped up but something
tells me he wasn't expecting all the
hate the singer's two lines of dialogue
were enough were son delight up Twitter
with comments like nothing takes me out
of a fantasy world like a random Ed
Sheeran appearance and I can't stand
insurance cameo so shade Wow I so did
internet trolls force Ed Sheeran off
Twitter because his account abruptly
disappeared yesterday for a bit which is
crazy because just over a week ago ed
cleared up rumors Lady Gaga fans flooded
him with so much hate he quit Twitter
still no explanation for the recent
shutdown but rest easy fans because Ed's
page is back up today how's this for a
plot twist he's deleted anything before
April of 2015 so Color Me confused
apparently not everyone is welcome in
Westeros ain't nobody got time for hate
let's talk about love Bachelorette
Rachel Lindsay is on her quest for the
one and has narrowed it down to three
people and our resident bachelor nation
expert lauren zima is back with the deep
on the dude with a final rose oh that is
right dude any guys we already know that
Rachel will be engaged by the end of the
season she's told us that so when I sat
down with her yesterday I had to put her
through the ringer I made that joke for
you
we got the scoop on her fiance find out
what we didn't know and find out about
her rock where are you keeping the ring
because you don't get to wear it it's a
good question I know it's not on this
finger I don't know where it is they
probably don't want to tell me because I
will go looking for it like I miss it
what is your favorite quality about your
fiance his strength
what about cringe-worthy moments
watching the show back the only
cringe-worthy moment I had was the hot
tub scene and having my family with beer
yeah when his hands are slowly gliding
up
back I'm sorry mom sorry dad that was
cringeworthy have you and your fiance
been watching the show I would prefer
that he didn't watch everything but he
needs to know like everything that's
going on so he can process everything
like that's just the kind of person that
he is
so watches at all what was the ultimate
deciding factor for you when it comes
down to those two guys it's really just
a feeling that x-factor mmm we're
reenacting the hot tub see we didn't
mind your age but that's right you guys
it was only cringe-worthy for her not
for us I'm also a little tidbit for you
I found out during the interview a
producer told me where that ring is
where does she's keeping it in her
cookie jar at home haha that's where all
the sweets that sweet stuff go right all
right who's it going to be the finale is
just around the corner but be sure to
check out Lauren's full recap of last
night's emotional Bachelorette on roses
and Rose a only on ETV youtube channel
Thank You Milus thanks everybody
so not the ring I don't have one yet
working on it are you guys that's it for
us today be sure to hit subscribe on ET
YouTube channel so you don't miss an
episode of daily Denny roses and Rose a
we've got so many great franchises
coming your way and as always stick with
ET online.com for the latest in
entertainment news bye everybody see you
on Wednesday